High any questions, any suggestions for low or below normal blood levels of
values of iron? Fair to levels are okay. Okay, like I said before, any test you do
have low iron, so I should just take iron, right? No, no, you've got to figure out why
you have low iron in the first place. Is your MCD, your MCHC, are your other
anaemic markers in the functional low range or high range? Is it a B12 deficiency? Is it
iron loss from bleeding disorder? Is it iron loss from excess bleeding during
periods? Is it, you got to figure out why do you have low iron? It could be
genetically related, it could be, there's just a ton of reasons, so you have to
be every time you do a test and there's an abnormal value, so if you do a blood
test, there's like, you know, you're you're you're tested 50 things of that
blood test, and there's four of them that are abnormal, you have to ask the
question, why? So why is this off? And it's very rarely as simple as, oh, you
just need to take some iron, you're just gonna be okay. If you do have primary
iron deficiency, you have to ask the question, why do you have that too? Is it
because you're not absorbed iron? Is it because you have a damaged cut? Is it
because you're screening it? Is it? It's just a lot of things you need to cover. I
hate to be such a past about this, but don't you want somebody that's gonna dig to
figure this out instead of just throwing stuff at the wall and opening sticks?